ciao vabbè ognuno ha il suo modo di
vedere la vittoria per me questa è la
vittoria tac attacca attacca che cazzo
succede aiuto o solo avviato il video
con il tasto per registrare parquet ma
si è staccato il tasto bellissimo non
amate ok stelle a tutti i ragazzi e per
la mia tastiera una merda però mi piace
con la tastiera non mi piace tutti
adesso subito poi la gente ragazzi
venuti questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo tornati su tutti a volta che ho
fatto è che mi sono fatto un episodio
speciale destra piaciuto e vi ringrazio
ragazzi per ripercorrere i vecchi
momenti è sempre bellissimo tra l'altro
ho appena aperto è il primo livello che
ho visto e questo oltre forza vj c'è non
è anche solo aprendo happy miss non ho
cercato niente c'è proprio mi è apparso
come primo livello quindi vediamo che
cazzate prova a vincere risate di
sottofondo stile telefilm anni 80 the
geni ho chiesto a genio hashtag sei un
genio
allora fatevi vedere che ti consiglio di
vincere provaci come minimo ma la bit
sono davanti la vittoria come faccio a
perdere nel possibile ma perché è
dimenticato di descrivere la parte in
cui sei stronzo ho capito è quindi
niente la vittoria alla fine bravo bravo
complimenti sia stato inizio ad odiarti
tra tutti i livelli che vi potrà
capitare
taci sua madre cioè il volto più
difficile che abbia mai fatto
e assurdo è bloccata anche la pia sei
stronzo proprio 6 crollando stronzo me
lo ricorderò chi sei ti vengo a cercare
la famiglia per test facciamo livelli
seri prima di tutto perché sennò hanno
aggiunto sta roba che si possono
cliccare le cose su happy feet come
cazzo fai fosse impossibile c'è figata
io ho una testa ho una testa e non ho
paura di usarla la vedi questa stronzata
la vista l'ha proprio vista m
mi sa che anche piaciuta a un culo
termiche o lancia scott addio questa
questa è la mia spalla tela presento
ciao babbo babbo prendi telo per favore
grazie e non allora mi serve che è stato
in gruppo e cos'è è uno stupro è una
gang bang si stanno incrociando tutte
fino eco vedi che finita ma non a babbo
natale che pallonetto fatto quel tizio
[Musica]
in chiaro mattino grande complimenti e
scorsa io continua affettare
ungheria sisti strano complimenti e
livello più bello che abbia mai fatto è
fatta mettere cosa che clicchi c'è
strani non hai cliccato sul web è scotta
frate con chi pensi di farla art un doge
madonna già fatta e va beh sono ancora
miccoli come possibile regole sono vivo
ok ma tranquilli e semplicemente ho
mangiato un po pesante
cos'è mondo disegnato a figo ci sarei
lampioni ci sono anche le [ __ ]
disegnate che figo ormai la grafica di
happiness è arrivata a livelli estremi
c'è proprio una roba che è che devo fare
col matita ha definito
complimenti frate segway ogni volta che
le questa parola mi sembra uno che si fa
una segue non so perché penso sempre
male delle cose allora datemi un senso
almeno ai livelli se li deve fare è di
almeno che abbiano sempre l arcobaleno è
piaciuto anche a edi la cosa fa per come
sto continuando a cavalcare il coso
anche senza braccia spiegatemi come è la
madonna si va beh ragazzi sta diventa
guida guarda cos'è saltando tutto il
livello su sultan solo perché ho perso
le gambe fantastico domando se manco io
se in volta presse z shape fox ormai
ragazzi stati devono essere accompagnati
da da da effetti sonori quali urli di
kek finale direi che la parte più bella
è stato al livello dell'anno ragazzi
world challenge that they koch ma zio ma
ti sta rendendo conto con chi stai
parlando no ce la posso fare tranquilli
pezzi no porca eva
vabbè ognuno ha il suo modo di vedere la
vittoria per me questa è la vittoria
attacca attacca attacca che cazzo
succede aiuto maschile a parte ragazzi
già possiamo fare attacca attacca i
ragazzi non ce la posso fare impossibile
ma che cazzo sto facendo media se
riuscirò a nava fan culo
sì sì
a me tante medaglie e un grosso pene di
schede può finalmente ed a migliana
tortura di saw l'enigmista questa nella
nota l'italia dagli bastardo dai ragazzi
ci credo sono vivo sono vivo cover
succhiami le mille euro sono imbalsamato
dove si è infilata la mannaia t'altro
sono ancora che sta facendo cioè stesso
in questo momento ragazzi l'anno 2015 si
fa sentire poi usare il mouse su lewis
c'è questa è questo e futuro tecnologia
mi stai prendendo per il culo ha alcun
senso
il fiume chiti ora champion amico mio
non sei 27 maggio probabilmente non
confavi j
quindi vuol dire che se lo fa luke e
avventure miglia campione di spaccate
manco lisa fusco per ora punta web
cos'è mica un attimo ed è uno dei
livelli più strani che abbiamo aspetta
ok
e vabbè vabbè se ok il resto diventa un
pò un casino
cosa ho fatto fermi tutti
sono io sono ancora vivo sono carriera
questo livello ci vuole un metteranno 10
è impossibile non voglio provare non
voglio sapere se vi va ok che lavora
tanta roba ragazzi tanta roba se ci
mette con gli archi amoni spiegate
ma si masturbano sugli atti a vanni
fatemi capire
com'è che questo piede sa di chanel
numero 5
non hai un calzino per carità di dio
però il test dell'arco che arco dovrebbe
essere fatemi capire a bello avere le
zie miglia che ciò non abbiamo una
figata rica migliaccio una mia ragazzi
che minacciano eccolo ne mancano ma
quante ferma meno male che sulle frecce
infinite sono sta minkia max click
adesso la mia vita ha un senso italia
italia italia 1 è esatto e c'è la tipa e
vabbè è morta
mi riempie il cuore giocare a ste robe
grazie mille impossible 70 per cento mi
viene dal cuore a dirtelo prosciugato
cosa ho fatto mi piace a me ne voglio
vedere mi piace checa che si cresce
youtube perché dopo questa premessa che
non paio di miei livelli visto che
quelli iniziali è stato abbastanza figo
gli altri non lo saranno ma quello
iniziale stato vicino anno muore no
questo non spoiler c'è già sfoderato il
finale quindi va bene già i quiz
c'è anche un po di troll forze deciditi
fammi capire cosa vuoi fare della
vigilia il macellaio facciamo lo stesso
post e segg abusavano ciak
ciao fa di questo livello di farlo quel
cappello dj cnel lavatrice il capo della
faccia un crollo di angri birds è uguale
zio che accade questa maniera un utero
non avrà un livello di merda zione non
dell'ordine mi spieghi cos'è miglia che
cosa fa un malato peggio di un piccione
fantastico ti lascio il piede come
ricordo grazie dio fa vj anatomy se
riesce a superare questo livello 6
christian gray versione videogiochi ma
che cazzo vuol dire cosa cazzo c'entra
christian greco i videogiochi sono morto
trovarti l'anti christian greider
dell'universo togliti cazzo di bidone ho
vinto sono cristian gray di videogiochi
cosa vuol dire che mi faccio il catarina
di league of legends magari
fanì già in caduta libera faccia
l'ultimo ragazze di pet wars percorso
c'è un nome della madonna a sovico sono
ricostruiva erosivo vaiolo jolo ha
sbagliato parte insieme a rob la danno a
[ __ ] mabar che cazzo vivo solo jolo
in caso sono morto va bene hai pazienza
e stato bello ragazzi complimenti x box
perché il tuo lavoro è stato bravo ciao
ragazzi concludo che l'episodio è stata
la cosa più strana ma che mettendo
insieme tutto quello che ho giocato
no no in generale comunque ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto oh mi piace perfetto
per the pops o ancora la lampada storta
ragazzi perché ormai abbiamo stretto un
rapporto d'amicizia comunqe i ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuta come
sento ragazze di dove è piaciuto il suo
momento mi piace anche al persiani
facebook e con i video trascrizione se
questi sistemi noi ci mettiamo passione
da ragazzi